I would like to thank you you and your
team new cabinet secretary repeatedly
and for guiding the European Council
effectively throughout cabinet the
secretary-general jpg and eBay for
guiding the European Council effectively
throughout the last two years we have
always followed the you mandate
scrupulously together with the UK we
have achieved decisive progress together
it's now up to you Dennard as president
of the European Council to decide and
convening an extraordinary meeting but
our work is not finished we still have a
long road a long road ahead of us on
both sides from my side in the next few
days we will all work on the text of the
political declaration on the future
relationship with the Member States as
well as with the European Parliament and
this work will be intense our goal is to
finalize this political declaration with
the UK so that the European Council can
endorse it I would travel now to stress
boom and discuss the state of play with
the European Parliament and take that
feedback and board in the final days of
negotiations we have no time to lose we
have no time to lose and now so now I
will give you
almost everything thank you very much so
I took good note of Prime Minister made
statement yesterday of course I don't
share the Prime Minister's enthusiasm
about drugs it as such since the very
beginning we have had no doubt that
dragged it is a lose-lose situation and
that our negotiations are only about
damage control
given these extremely difficult
circumstances I would like to thank
Michelle Barney and his team especially
Sabine valiant and Stephanie Rizzo for
doing this exceptionally hard work shall
we all put a lot of trust in you and
rightly so you have achieved our two
most important objectives first you
ensured the limitation of the damage
caused by Brazil and second you secured
the vital interest and principles of the
27 member states and of the European
Union as a whole if I weren't confident
that you did your best to protect the
interests of the 27 and I'm familiar
with the essence of the document I would
not propose to formalize this deal in
the next days we'll proceed as follows
the agreement is now being analyzed by
all the Member States by the end of this
week the eu-27 ambassadors will meet in
order to share the assessment of the
agreement I hope that there will not be
too many comments they will also discuss
the mandate for the Commission to
finalize the joint politic
decoration about the future relations
between the EU and the UK the European
ministers will be involved in this
process the Commission intends to agree
the declaration about the future with
the UK by Tuesday over the following 48
hours the member states will have time
to have it evaluated which means that
the eu-27 Sherpas should conclude this
work on Thursday then if nothing
extraordinary happens we will hold the
European Council meeting in order to
finalize and formalize the braket
agreement it will take place on Sunday
the 25th of November at 9:30 a.m.
finally let me say this to our British
friends as much as I am sad to see you
leave I will do everything to make this
farewell that is painful possible for
both for you and for us thank you thank
you
[Music]
a handshake there between the ears chief
negotiator Michelle Barney and the
European Council President Donald Tusk
clutching in his left hand there the 585
draft agreement which Teresa may has
gotten past her cabinet another date to
add to your diary however at Sunday the
25th of November half past 9:00 in the
morning and that will be the point at
which the European Council will meet to
fight to formalize at that agreement on
brexit if of course nothing happens here
domestically I'd time to check in on the
weather
Isabel's here